hey everyone its Johanna here so I've
decided to dedicate an entire video to
my love for green tea I drink my green
tea every single day and I love
everything about it so let's start by
understanding the way green tea is
processed and why it has much more
health benefits in comparison to black
tea black tea is fermented to give it a
dark color on the other hand green tea
is made from unfermented leaves which
are simply heated after picking by
either steaming or dry roasting to
minimize oxidation as the result green
tea hosts the maximum amount of
antioxidants and is highly regarded as a
health drink of course there are many
more different types of teas but we
won't get into in this video let's just
focus on green tea for now so what are
some of the different types of green tea
there are actually quite a huge variety
of green teas but let me just share with
you some of the common green teas Long
Jing which is more commonly known as
Dragon Well green tea is from China and
is one of the most popular green tea
Sanja is known as the everyday Japanese
green tea and is very commonly consumed
in Japan and also around the world
Matt Chou is a powdered Japanese green
tea and this tea is commonly used in
Japanese tea ceremony can like char
which is also known as Popkin tea is my
favorite green tea all this green tea
packs here again my char it is actually
Sancho T which is pan fired and combined
with toasted brown rice I like it
because of the extra toasted flavor from
the brown rice you can also check out
this link below for a comprehensive list
of green teas from China and
pen so which type of green tea is the
best generally they are all good it is
important to know that a high-quality
green tea does not have a storage life
of more than six months so if you have
ever tasted green tea and you don't
really like it it tends to be from your
average grocery stores which is much low
in quality heavily blended and not very
fresh if you want to get the maximum
benefits from your green tea and of
course the best taste try Japanese or
Chinese grocers they tend to carry
better green teas and of course your
health stores to go for powdered or
loose leaf teas for maximum antioxidants
over tea bags loose leaf teas are made
from Holies bigger pieces of leaves and
tend to be fresher with short storage
life in contrast of a tea funning
teabags are usually made from small
pieces of tea leaves or tea Fanning's
which is quicker to brew but it lacks
the full flavor and health benefits they
tend to have a much longer storage life
which means they are not as fresh and
they will tend to lose lots of nutrients
but of course there will be some health
benefits as well so which Japanese or
Chinese green tea should you buy that I
would say really comes down to personal
taste and preference be open and keep
exploring the different kinds of green
teas and eventually you will find your
favorite when I stumble upon again my
child I was hooked and I've only been
drinking this ever since so explore and
let me know which is your favorite green
tea so now that you know more about
green tea why should you drink it every
day and what are some of the benefits
green tea contains a potent plant
nutrient also known as let me get this
right
epic gellar catechins galat or EGCG
4-shot EGCG has been studied to treat
various disease and is a natural
medicine the first benefit green tea is
a super fat fighter and helps towards
weight loss it's active ingredient EGCG
increases the rates of fat being burned
in our body we are recommended to drink
3 cups a day to increase our metabolic
rate however it is important to know
that green tea only increases our
metabolism by 4 percent which is about
80 calories a day so drinking green tea
alone will not help towards a
significant weight loss it is a
combination of regular exercises and
healthy eating
having said that green tea can help to
maintain a healthy weight and why not
burn some additional calories even
though it's a small amount because it
will help towards your weight loss in
long term you will be happy to know the
second benefit green tea targets
abdominal fat the EGCG in the green tea
activates fat burning genes in the
abdomen to speed weight loss by 77% so
drinking green tea on a daily basis will
help towards burning belly fat long-term
green tea helps to reduce bloating and
improves digestion it is a very powerful
diuretic which helps to relieve bloating
and avoid water retention so if you were
to drink green tea on a daily basis you
will notice that you will visit the
toilet more often to get rid of excess
water and toxic in your body which
actually helps towards a flat belly or
if you tend to experience feeling really
bloated after a meal try to drink a cup
of green tea which will help your body
to digest your food easily another
reason to drink green tea via 9 an amino
acid found in green tea can help with
relaxation and focus on a personal
experience I have to agree with this I
drink my green tea every morning either
before or with my breakfast and it
really helps to keep me calm and focus
right from the start of the day green
tea is also a great stress reliever so
whenever you get stressed out instead of
binging try to drink
cup of green tea to calm yourself down
or drink green tea whenever you're
studying or even working the fifth
reason it keeps our energy stable by
balancing our blood sugar levels this
will prevent blood sugar spikes or
crashes which can result in fatigue
irritability or cravings for unhealthy
food
green tea drinkers tend to be more in
control of their cravings and this can
also help towards binge eating so if
you're one of those person who is
constantly craving for more food even
when you are full try to drink green tea
every day and drink it with your meals
regular consumption of green tea also
help with longevity and looking young
EGCG is 200 times more powerful than
vitamin E to destroy skin damaging free
radicals
hence consuming green tea on a regular
basis were cute free radicals avoid skin
damaging wrinkles and other signs of
aging I genuinely believe that this is
one of the agent secret to youth boost
skin because we tend to consume green
tea on a daily basis you might not be
aware of this but green tea improves
dental health and reduces bad breath
unlike coffee which gives you bad breath
green tea does the total opposite the
anti bacterial and natural fluoride
found in green tea kills bacteria which
causes cavity tooth decay gum diseases
and bad breath so if you have a busy day
ahead you might want to consider
swapping your coffee with green tea this
powerful drink may also lower your risk
of cancer cancer is caused by
uncontrolled growth of cells and it is
one of the world's leading causes of
death EGCG is known to prevent lung
blarin stomach esophageal and breast
cancer by suppressing cancer growing
cells it has also been said that
drinking green tea before and after
so surgery significantly lowers the risk
of its reoccurrence so let's start
drinking green tea because prevention is
better than cure another health benefit
is green tea reduces bad cholesterol in
the blood and increases the good
cholesterol so this will help prevent
cardiovascular disease which is
currently the number one cause of deaths
in America so now that you know the
benefits of green tea how many cups
should you drink a day to gain the
maximum benefits there has been lots of
conflicting opinions on this sunset as
little as two cups some five cups and
some even up to 10 cups
I drink about 4 to 5 cups a day and I
would say that is a safe amount yes
green tea does contain caffeine but it
is much lower in comparison to coffee
one cup of green tea has about 35
milligram of caffeine whereas coffee has
between 100 to 200 milligrams of
caffeine
so the first infusion of green tea
releases the most caffeine and it starts
to reduce with a second and third
infusion if you are someone who is
sensitive to its cafe your limit should
only be one cup a day and try to go for
the third or second infusion so how to
make your green tea to get the maximum
flavor the first step is to bring a pot
of water to boil and allow it to stand
for two to three minutes because we do
not want the water to be boiling hot add
one or two teaspoons of tea leaves into
a tea pot pour the heated water and
allow the tea leaves to steam for up to
three minutes and enjoy your glass of
green tea if you were to steep the green
tea for more than three minutes it can
be rather bitter than flavorful you can
enjoy it hot or cool you can add a
little bit of flavor if you want to like
a squeeze of lemon or even ginger
whatever you do do not add milk to your
green tea the casing in the milk
inhibits the benefits of
see plus it is just weird and you will
not be able to gather maximum benefits
if you were to add sugar or artificial
sweeteners green tea on its own it's so
flavorful and so healthy in fact it is
zero in calories so why add all the
extras it is just not needed so to
conclude green tea is not something you
would start drinking for a couple of
months and then stop to gain the maximum
health benefits long-term drinking on a
regular basis every day I would only
drink water or green tea and without
fill I will have my green tea every
morning when I'm at home I will have
holies and when I'm traveling I would
carry the teabags with me of course they
may not be as fresh but it is my daily
devotion to green tea for new fitness
food and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my You Tube
channel and website do you follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
you